what is Nile's dream date well I always
liked when I remember like growing up
and you couldn't go anywhere and like I
always hated the idea of like Cinema
remember like Cinema used to be a day
like when you were young especially
coming from small town did you do the um
yeah yeah all that stuff I mean it's the
worst thing in the world to do to go to
the cinema
just like pure silence you have to watch
the movie when you when do you get a
chance to actually get to know anyone
um so no not day uh not that I would say
good restaurant that you can both agree
on is good
um and then maybe go to the pub
afterwards because I feel like people
are more relaxed than pubs I think we
like the idea of
sitting down at the fancy restaurant
table and doing all that stuff but the
more relaxed you can be on a date the
better